don't know on on that bill bill gates
posited this idea of creative capitalism
in which he broadened the the notion
that the one can have an ethical company
and a company can i play a broader role
than just profit maximization for
shareholders and in that way we can
actually see multiple returns to society
beyond you know the the great product
that the company makes or for the
shareholder money that they will give as
a residual because that's their money to
give but the company itself can be
ethical and have an impact but a lot of
people oppose that view and say no
companies should be limited to profit
maximization sort of in the friedman
sense do you agree with that I think
profit maximization is really a too
narrow of a definition in the role the
company I might say I'm more on Bill
Gates aside on this that you know the
company is is a member of the community
in some sense and needs to play a role
in the broad broadly defined community
and you know you have to be careful
about it because certainly you have to
pay attention to profits and investors
is one very key element of that
community because if you don't pay
attention to them they're not going to
keep financing your company and you're
not going to have a company and all your
wonderful things for employees are going
to go away so I think you know it's a
balancing act it's all about being
balanced but I think that part of that
balance is are those other
constituencies so I don't understand the
notion of taking one constituency
investors and putting them way above all
of those other constituencies to me that
that's not doesn't make sense
intellectually but it also doesn't make
sense for the long-term health of the
company i think the long-term health of
a company will be far better if the
company is trying to balance all those
constituencies having a great place for
employees to work for example you can
say investors would be better served if
you try to pay people the lowest
possible amount but i think in the end
investors are better served if the
employees are happy
and thriving and building careers and
enjoying themselves and being creative
and innovative so you know it all plays
together it's very complex